build it draw it play it Vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people this is B
team building seams Tourette
instructables.com made this r2d2 bra or
the art - double D - as he likes to call
equipped with lights and sounds made
from paper mache and the lights and
sounds come from an old r2d2 toy he also
has an easier duct tape version for
novice crafters find the link below
Calvin Siebert has taken the art of
making sand castles to the next level
with these geometric shapes he says it's
like a test because nature is always
against you and time is always running
out he starts by making the basic shapes
with his hands and then uses a simple
plastic spackle tool to do the precision
work and he works on them until the
tides come in and wash them away leaving
him with a clean new canvas Tony swattin
is a blacksmith that recreates weapons
from TV shows and movies
here he is forging the sword Jaime
Lannister from Game of Thrones other
creations include he-man sword Batman's
batarangs Raphael sighs odd jobs hat and
fins golden sword from adventure time
check out his fantastic YouTube channel
for more draw artist star revise
recreates modern day video games into
old-school Atari cartridges including
Skyrim fallout 3 Grand Theft Auto
Minecraft and Mass Effect check out the
full collection at her deviantART page
artist Adams Spisak makes some amazing
illustrations of popular TV characters
such as Dexter Rick from Walking Dead
Don Draper from Mad Men and Walter from
Breaking Bad all are available for
purchase so check out the website in the
link below and now for the SNL inspired
art of the is this thing on
- art show going on at gallery 1988
[Music]
in flight Ezequiel Galasso of Buenos
Aires makes guitars out of use trashed
up skateboard decks and here's one of
escape guitars in action mega popular
violinist Lindsey Stirling and the
incredible voice of Peter Holland's
combined to cover the theme from Game of
Thrones
[Music]
finally my good friends barely political
made a tribute to ridiculous singing
voices in our new video with cdza
[Music]
submit your bidipis as a personal
message here on youtube or share them
with everyone over at
facebook.com/vsaucetwo wo
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
click here to listen to a brand new
installment of bdp radio music created
and submitted by you guys also check out
your VDP an entire video dedicated to
your creations and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]